Senator Dick Durbin of Illinois is the
number two Democrat in the Senate and a
member of the Judiciary Committee he
joins us from Capitol Hill senator good
to see you thank you so much for joining
us good to be with you so as of this
morning does it look like Brett
Kavanaugh will become the next Supreme
Court justice well it's not clear of
course we have four members of the
Senate three Republicans in one Democrat
who have not announced what their final
vote will be there's a test vote a
procedural vote this morning which will
give us an indication yes we just went
went through all that for our viewers
let me ask you the fellow Democrat Joe
Manchin of West Virginia will he vote
for Cavanaugh you know set through a
dozen or more meetings with Joe on the
subject he's kept his own counsel
he's obviously weighing this thing from
a personal point of view he understands
the historic impact I could not tell you
as I stand here how Joe's gonna vote are
you trying to lobby senator Manchin well
you know it's a little different in the
Senate twisting arms doesn't work a bit
the best thing you can do is to just try
to talk it through in terms of the issue
itself in this case the nomination the
impact that's going to have on the party
on the nation certainly on the state
that the senator represents but you
don't twist arms at this level Democrats
have made it clear senator they are not
happy with the FBI inquiry what do you
wish they would have done well let me
tell you what a disappointment I said in
that room yesterday and went through
this scant
survey they made of about ten witnesses
maybe nine at most and I thought to
myself even these witnesses were
identifying people who should have been
talked to the FBI didn't they were
clearly under orders to limit this
investigation and as a result there were
many witnesses eight of them suggested
by dr. Ford 20 by Miss Ramirez who were
never even contacted by the FBI it was a
very disappointing effort senator is
there anything that Democrats in
particular could have done differently
to make this a late less painful process
for dr. Ford I don't think so I think we
went out of our way to try to bend to
her wishes you remember when she first
came forward she branded her letter
confidential and made it clear she
didn't want her identity disclosed
senator Feinstein respected that request
did not want to victimize her another
time and so time pass
and that's been used against senator
Feinstein I'd say unfairly if she was
trying her best
specifically senator based on this FBI
inquiry there is still no one that
corroborates dr. Ford's account of what
happened in fact there is even some
testimony by Leland Kaiser her friend
that she she told the FBI she felt
pressured to change what she had said
why wasn't there any corroboration who
should have been interviewed that you
think could have corroborated her
account well there could have been at
least eight people that were suggested
by dr. Ford that could have been
interviewed I certainly think that Marc
judge in this circumstance should have
been brought in under oath and asked
questions there were elements of his
statement that I can't disclose but they
certainly raise questions which should
have been pursued what's your feeling
about his op-ed this morning judge
Cavanaugh as he admits that he got a
little too emotional but he says he can
return to being in his words even keeled
open-minded and independent were you
moved by what he had to say no I'm not I
understand his emotion and his anger
that this has to be a terrible ordeal
for him and his family and I understand
that part but the fire in his eyes when
he turned into this partisan scree is
something I'm not going to forget I
cannot imagine the Supreme Court justice
who would be so partisan make such wild
claims and then ask to be put on a bench
and trusted his temperament when I agree
with Justice John Paul Stevens this
should not take place well senator if he
does make the court what then does this
do to the Supreme Court I don't know you
take a look at Clarence Thomas he spent
10 years and sullen silence over the
experience that he went through if we go
through and put Brett Kavanaugh on the
court got I just don't know what he's
going to do with that
they don't trust his temperament at this
point his demeanor that is a really a
basic element when it comes to good
jurisprudence I'm afraid he has told us
things and said things that give us an
indication he's not ready for the
highest court in the land all right
senator dick durbin thanks so much for
being with us